also but we begin tonight we turn to the
presumptive nominee for the Democratic
Party Joe Biden the ever forgetful one
who is now vowing to fight his words
structural racism in America now he's
doing this from the comfort the security
of his basement bunker and today he
tweeted quote nothing about the fights
that we're facing will be easy racism
has been a fixture in our society for
hundreds of years but I'm ready to get
to work on day one we can't expect
anything less from an American president
well the ever forgetful Joe must be
confused yet again because his day one
was actually over 40 years ago and he
now has a track record that does not
match his rhetoric now way back in 1973
he was first sworn in as a u.s. senator
so what did Biden do to end racism
during his six terms in the US Senate
his two terms as Vice President of the
United States that is the subject of
tonight's Hannity investigation into
Biden and the issue of race relations
forty years of failure we begin let's
start in 1973 during his speech
then-senator Joe Biden he praised
Southern Democrats and he said that the
two-party system in the south was quote
good for bleep I can't say it around the
same time Biden was actively working
with D segregationists in their order to
slow integration he opposed school
busing according to NBC News quote he
led the charge on an issue that kept
black students away from the classrooms
of white students 1977 Biden worried
that his children would grow up in a
quote racial his words jungle if
integration is not done in a quote
orderly way whatever that means and in
1993 he referred to inner-city youth as
quote predators on our streets and he
co-authored a very aggressive crime bill
well that ramped up prison sentences for
dozens of crimes we've got the video
evidence the videotape let's go to it it
doesn't matter whether or not they're
the victims of society the end result is
they're about to knock my mother on the
head with a lead pipe shoot
my sister beat up my wife taken on my
sons so I don't want to ask what made
them do this they must be taken off the
street we should focus on them now not
out of a liberal instinct for love
brother and humanity although I think
that's a good instinct but for simple
pragmatic reasons if we don't they will
or a portion of them will become the
Predators 15 years from now and Madam
President we have predators on our
streets let's continue when the crime
bill became law Biden was so proud of
his accomplishment he bragged quote the
liberal wing of the Democratic Party is
now for 60 new death penalty 70 enhanced
penalties a hundred thousand new cops a
hundred and twenty five thousand new
state prison cells this is the same guy
that pretended to be a civil rights
leader four years after all in 1987 he
lied about marching in the civil rights
protest well recently he lied about
getting arrested by the apartheid South
African government while on his way to
see Nelson Mandela few weeks ago he lied
about as many political endorsements
from the n-double a-c-p they don't
endorse they never endorsed him and by
the way what did he do to fix systemic
racism okay it was under Barack and Jose
watch Ferguson happened Baltimore
happened Cambridge police happened
Trayvon Martin George Zimmerman happened
that was when he was vice president so
what did he do to fix the systemic
racism in the 70s the 80s the 90s the
2000s in other words does that sound
does this what we're about to play you
sound like a man who's particularly
worried about racism to you you decide
take a look the largest broken
population
in America you cannot go to unless you
have a slight Indian accent what kind of
a chance with a northeastern liberal
like Joe Biden stand in the South better
than anybody else you don't know my
state my state was a slave state my
state is a border state my state is the
eighth largest black population in the
country we've got the first
[Music]
they're gonna put y'all back in Chains
we can keep going first mainstream
african-american first one who's
articulate bright and clean there's a
story book what believe it or not as
rhetoric has actually gotten much worse
few weeks ago Biden told radio host
Charlie Charlemagne the god the
following you decide it's a long wait
until November we got more questions you
got more questions without telling if
you have a problem figuring out whether
your for mere Trump and you ain't black
pretty obvious white Biden spends most
of his days hiding in his basements
Democrats are now being caught on tape
they don't want anyone actually see the
real Joe Biden the lying the weird
statements the racial rhetoric the
constant confusion question in America's
gonna have to ask and answer in 146 days
is Joe Biden fit to serve as the
commander and chief and the President of
the United States does he have the
mental alertness the stamina the
strength to take on what is the hardest
job in the world is he up for the job
what's gonna happen when he finally has
to leave his basement bunker now even
longtime Clinton hack Terry McAuliffe he
wants Biden stay in the basement keep
him in the basement long as possible out
of the spotlight keep him in the
basement keep him there he does a couple
of calls today he's good
take a look people say all the time oh
we got to get the vice president of a
basement he's fine in the basement two
people see him a day he's too bad he
people Lassa and let Trump keep doing
with Trump's doing it's hard for the
vice president to break through there's
a whole new strategy for winning the
office of president hide in your
basement quite a statement at some point
before November yep the forgetful Joe
Biden will be forced to actually leave
the basement and campaign and debate and
even Biden's closest supporters are
nervous I could tell you Democrats are
telling me privately they are scared to
death as soon as he opens his mouth and
rightfully so Biden will have to keep
track of decades of ever-evolving lies
political posturing as
Sothis if Donald Trump had this history
do you think the mainstream media mob
would give him a pass or would they be
asking him questions all of the time now
for example right now he's once again
pretending to be on the forefront of
equality he says he wants to quote
urgently root out systemic racism from
policing the housing opportunities in
his recent op-ed I wonder who wrote it
did you write it yourself Joe Payne at
America's police with a broad brush
calling them systematically racist the
ones he was bragging about hiring when
he was bragging about the crime bill and
all the predators that are on the street
doing so he's turning on the very police
that he once claimed to support that's
the case is joe the forgetful one gonna
say all of that he has armed security he
has Secret Service agents that risk
their lives daily to keep him alive
rightly so my mind is he going to say
that to them now we have said on this
show there are bad apples in the police
we saw that in all of what has gone on
here with George Floyd vast majority of
them of those people that serve their
communities they serve with honor and
distinction
they protect and they serve every police
officer I know was shocked as the nation
was by what they saw in the case of mr.
Floyd and Biden's disrespecting the
decent men and women who do serve their
communities day in and day out the good
cops protecting and serving serving
their communities he's disrespecting
those who have fallen in the line of
duty including those who bravely rushed
into burning buildings in New York to
remember everyone's trying to escape
this whole group of other people firemen
paramedics policemen on their way up to
save lives 9/11 2001 to save their
fellow man they were heroes to all of us
then have we forgotten and according to
the most recent data from the DOJ well
over 750 federal state local officers
have been injured in last week's riots
that claim by the way the lives of over
20 people in DC 22 police officers they
were hospitalized after getting pelted
let's see with bricks and rocks and
bottles Molotov cocktails thrown at
their heads others were charged with Amy
laser at a law enforcement aircraft and
throwing explosives into police cars and
so much more
one Las Vegas police officer shot in the
head last week he might need now a
ventilator for the rest of his life and
we must never forget
retired st. Louis police captain David
Dorn 38 years he served his community
with honor and distinction he was
murdered attempting to protect a local
store from looters these so many of them
the overwhelming majority I always say
that 99% they are heroes they're not
villains but in order to please this
Angry far left-wing base Biden is now
using them as mere political pawns when
it serves his interests they're heroes
they're stopping predators when it
doesn't serve his interest he turns on
them in seconds